-Finally people here.
Just amazing, right?
-Are they real?
-This is real. This is real.
They're here.
Yes, they are real.
You guys real? Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you guys real?
Okay, I guess.
-How does it feel?
The album is now out officially.
-I'm so grateful, man.
Really grateful.
I mean, I can't wait
to see the feedback,
the love of the people,
you know?
-I love -- "In Da Getto"
which you're doing tonight
is unbelievable catchy,
and everybody will get a taste
of how awesome that is.
But since we've talked,
so much has gone on.
You're releasing new music.
You did a live Halloween special
on "Fortnite."
-Yes.
-By the way, which --
Which I did not see, because I
have not played "Fortnite" yet.
'Cause I'm afraid
because I heard it's so good
that I'll just
get addicted to it.
-Yes.
-But then you sent me this
in the mail yesterday,
and you have your own skin
in "Fortnite."
Look at this. Is that
the way to do it or what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
How cool is that?
-Thank you.
-So now I'm gonna start playing
because of you.
-Oh, go ahead.
-Yeah.
-You're gonna love it.
-Yeah, I'm going to. Yeah.
How does it --
-You start playing with me or --
-Yeah, I'll play --
Well, you play as you, right?
-You're gonna play with me.
-Yeah, I play with you.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I don't play against you.
I don't play against J Balvin.
-Alright, alright.
-When you play as you, and I'm
assuming you have, is it odd?
-Me playing with myself is --
[ Laughter ]
Wait, wait, no, wait, no --
-No, no, no, no, wait, whoa --
I like to play --
-As --
-As, you know --
I like to play with myself,
but, like, when --
[ Laughter ]
Why you gotta
be like that, guys?
No, I like to play, you know,
with this guy right here --
-Okay, okay, we still --
Yes, okay.
-I try to play with my skin,
with my own skin in "Fortnite."
I mean the --
Not my skin, you know.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to have to make some
edits.
Yeah, yeah, no, no, yeah, yeah,
on the "Fortnite" skin --
-Yeah, thank you.
-It's almost getting so weird.
Just don't say any more.
[ Laughter ]
It's just classic. Look how red.
Your face is so red right now.
-Sorry, Mom. Sorry, Mom.
-How about this for a segue?
Your face is almost as red
as you as Spider-Man
in Times Square.
How about that for a segue?
This is how cool this guy is.
So he goes to Times Square.
Dresses up as Spider-Man.
-Yep.
-For real
and then goes, hangs out
with all the other Spider-Men.
This is you
hanging from the pole.
That's you. That's actually --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, what happened --
How did -- What happened
with people
when you took the mask off?
-I mean, as Spider-Man,
I don't know why.
They hate me.
You know, I was like,
"Hey, what's up?"
They were like,
"No, no, get away."
And I was like, "I thought
being Spider-Man was cool."
-Of course.
-I mean, should be cool
but I was like, "Hey, you gonna
take a picture with me?"
Like, "Hell, no." Like, "No."
-Yeah. Of course.
Yeah, no, you're okay, yeah.
-And then --
-Took the mask off.
-And then I took the mask off,
and they, "Oh, J Balvin,
man, I love you," so...
-It's almost better
to be J Balvin.
-I think it was
better to be J Balvin,
but I love Spider-Man.
I can't --
-Yeah.
-I can't lie.
-The album is finally out.
We can say it's out.
-It's out now, yeah.
-The last album was "Colores."
-"Colores" during pandemic.
-During the --
Exactly, but then you came on --
Nice enough to come on our show
for that. Thank you.
This one is "Jose."
-Yeah.
-And --
-"Jose."
-Yes.
-Yeah, with a little "hho"
and a little "say."
-Yes.
-Alright.
-"Jose."
-Yeah.
-Yeah. So, "Jose."
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, that is your name.
so I'm assuming this is
a very personal album?
-It is, it is. It's my,
like, my own playlist
of what I would love to hear
from my genre, you know?
Like, it's like just so personal
it's just like --
Like how I would love to listen
from another audience,
but I'm the one who's singing,
you know?
-Yeah, exactly right.
-Kind of weird,
yes, I know, but --
But that's the idea.
Really personal.
-There were rumors of you
announcing a tour
or going on tour,
and you haven't done anything
or said anything
that you're going to,
but is there anything
you would like to tell me?
[ Laughter ]
-Besides that I love you?
-Yeah. Besides I love you,
'cause I love you, too.
-Man, oh, thank you.
-But are you thinking of a tour?
-Yes, we -- We going on sale
next week.
-You actually are going on tour?
-Yes.
-Dude!
-Jose's tour!
-"Jose" tour!
-Yeah.
-I knew it, I knew it. No way.
-Yeah, we're going to start
in the West, yeah.
-Start in the West.
-Are you guys ready?
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
Go see J Balvin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also want to say that
I follow you on all the socials,
and there's a TikTok trend
of your new song, "In Da Getto,"
but can you teach me
the challenge,
or can you teach me the dance?
-Are you down?
-I'm me, but I'm down.
If you do it, I'll do anything
with you, man.
-You want to try?
-Teach me how to do it.
-Thank you. Where you
want to be? Here, there?
-I could do it here. Yeah, sure.
Do you want to --
-I got to shout-out to Mufasa
who taught me the moves
and Delfina and my friend.
So, you know --
-Yeah. Oh, wait, who'd you learn
it from? Yeah, who did this?
-Yeah, Mufasa.
-Uh-Huh.
-It's a great dancer.
-Yeah.
-Then Amir from Argentina.
-And Delfina from Uruguay,
so, like, cool people.
-Wow. Alright. So it takes all
around the world to teach --
-You ready?
-Here we go. Here's the jam.
-Okay.
[ "In Da Getto" playing ]
-Ay. Ay. Ay.
-Like that?
-Now from the side.
[ Cheers and applause ]
1, 2, 3, go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, that's how you do it
right there.
Dude, I can do that part.
That's where I got lost,
where I go, yeah.
That's J Balvin, everybody!
Check out his new album, "Jose,"
which is out right now!